okay [ __ ] is at your Bush psychobabble
sorry but that apparently my [ __ ]
microphone just turned off I don't know
why the last one was really having you
talk anyway
we're doing the supply rate operation
spending time let's do this
also I installed a time to cut out all
that [ __ ] waiting you know like
after you do he'll be on the way like a
second or two so hopefully it's better I
can see with these pictures again sniper
at those number okay what shotgun go
[ __ ] yourself [ __ ]
okay just go [ __ ] yourself um okay let's
do that I'll fire generating Sun and I'm
also not learn [ __ ] headphones
because any second now pizzas going to
come from don't feel like an hour order
P does that I talk and I can come on
come on Babbitt second mission operation
fed and tongue cat I burn okay choosing
Commission's of manager shut down
operation sanitizing neutralize all n
natori of my favorite men and as secure
a lot a shotgun so we're moving in to
take advantage neutralize any more
Chinese meao
secure the Cylon and lockdown Erica
cargo thanks a fascist scheana's
hopefully it takes like two seconds now
menace 1 5 cat coordinates of the Advent
train are locked in move to secure
eliminate apples got got its go over
there
get goin you piece of [ __ ]
yeah painted shut and right there yes
yes yes and the Sun we are one oh yes
[ __ ] [ __ ] and let's go over
here yes alright do that so right yeah
that's right run through the dart that's
what I pay if I am a better Hannah okay
okay in the song we are one and the Sun
we are together thank God
oh great a piece of [ __ ] play that piece
of [ __ ]
there you go okay should I shoot this
[ __ ] no no no look da [ __ ] okay that
was really socked out like a bag that
was really hooked up sorry you have to
see that guys I'm sorry you have to see
that
okay um sometimes things in life don't
go as planned
okay where where am I
where the [ __ ] is that okay
there we go pop this [ __ ]
pop this [ __ ] and you you can't shoot
two things that's [ __ ]
you can't jump [ __ ] why can I shoot that
guy
mmm pocket moving on target over there
is detected but I'm going to give a [ __ ]
yep we're gonna say
okay all right
five that's [ __ ] did I [ __ ] it in this
oh my god where's the guy with the drone
drone [ __ ] he's gone with the drone [ __ ]
I'm sure
can't kill this bench cyanide popsicles
gasified okay another snitch he can go
up here yep good copy
moving on target cue a sniper now Advent
troops spotted
okay fascinating let's up [ __ ] it's my
turn isn't it yeah don't [ __ ] her that
about anyways sir
maybe there's a guy I could [ __ ] fry
Bob's away just dad yeah yeah throw that
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that
steam out the introduction of human DNA
these creatures once operating under the
guise of thin men now show their true
form a purely reptilians [ __ ] mark no
reason for the alien infiltration unit
anymore
Oh [ __ ] critical shut and that don't
you have these days not doing throughout
these days okay what what - yawns just
suck a dick or what what's that
oh okay um this guy should really know
let's switch my next person okay here we
go
um right exit where's the collar
vertical okay well I should build on
this guy pocket [ __ ] reptilian bench
take that now he doesn't give a [ __ ]
this [ __ ] right here should definitely
go for this guy dirty
[ __ ] I'll get him next time sir move
that [ __ ] 31%
no thank you grenade
I move right there okay look a little
language and try and take out this
microfiche equipment we're after we'll
have to do our best to avoid destroying
the gear while we secure the area
yeah [ __ ] wrecked Kill Confirmed
interesting let's hook a that up chef
fuckin'-a getting fire back at the fence
a big [ __ ] mess
well good what the [ __ ] was that
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] all right dad
let's adjust that second knot
he's still bound
what's a chance to hit a mistake where
you 1% [ __ ] rube here yeah
moving on target little Papa stood
[ __ ] tough Kill Confirmed okay
this [ __ ] who I have something with
lightning hands puck um
right there I'm moving out
I'm sure pops dude pistol what [ __ ]
myth
not even close alright [ __ ] kill them
what the [ __ ] he's so slippery
she said that's [ __ ] messed up in
here Thanks
she's fired
yeah you go holy [ __ ] alright looks like
we weren't ready for that looks like we
weren't ready for that okay that's all I
gotta say
we got [ __ ] our dick sucked and
that's what we get
where can I get I need to buy some
[ __ ] armor not engineering what can I
do for you commander dolls items [ __ ]
need some armor let's battle skin
okay highlight one I've had a chance to
take a closer look at some of the Advent
weapons recovered from the field
the alloy used in their frames is
significantly lighter making money okay
looks like we're doing it again [ __ ]
okay we put the realism go back in gosh
we're going back in
she is the [ __ ] general okay she need
some [ __ ] armor now Kevlar armor dust
[ __ ] and I switch the armor
okay
I'm [ __ ] doing this shotgun
go [ __ ] yourself [ __ ] the only thing
I'm gonna [ __ ] is a shotgun oh you
joking on me okay we're going back in
we're going back in okay did I Ranger
deployed in position for deployment back
to fading tongue okay
recon indicates an Advent train was
recently different keep talking about
greater resistance I'm talking about
hunger haven't managed to move it out of
the region we're heading in to seize any
assets and technology we find neutralize
all hostile contacts and secure the AO
took the phones for charging like 10
years now okay
there we go look at the math randomize
the [ __ ] math is were analyzed
eliminate oh [ __ ] okay well obviously we
gotta get to high ground Babic save this
game no save no sad and get where's my
sniper [ __ ]
where's my Perella vega she is getting
the [ __ ] lead the [ __ ] why can't she
go over there there we go
getting it done and go go go
it's getting crazy okay I'll get them
all that's the event we're after we'll
have to do our best to avoid destroying
the gear while we secure the area
rolling item we are [ __ ] ShadowClan
right now we are ShadowClan okay that's
right [ __ ] I don't have a hundred
percent shot [ __ ] it
obviously a better liar right position
where's [ __ ] where's Cinderella here
that's affirmative
okay they're [ __ ] where's my alien
around here somewhere
what is this
oh [ __ ]
with this guy now
Roger that we're sending one soldier
indeed she's [ __ ] going what the [ __ ]
forty-four percent chance now brow now
fresh blood is [ __ ] so Marines
moving to position okay you gonna fire
this [ __ ] fire out weapon papa
just pop up what stop let's just pop
this [ __ ]
take this that's what I'm talking about
that right that is what I am talking
about oh [ __ ] sorry you got out of there
confirmed
okay so how it just has a void okay [ __ ]
I don't know what's over there I'm all
over it
now without the introduction of human
DNA
these creatures once operating under the
guise of been mid now show their true
form okay this clip has to go over here
no reason for them to hide the aliens
don't need an infiltration unit anymore
pocket Aegina nothing you're [ __ ]
right there location confirmed now
[ __ ] it go over there that's good having
egg
[Music]
orders confirmed moving out
alright let's see what's gonna do what
the [ __ ] I don't feel so good
I'm sure you don't [ __ ] okay can I pop
that sucker 71 have a killer stow it
nail them okay
this bench now I had a pretty good
chance
oh and let go we go kill a fish kelan
[ __ ] na is it kinda hard to [ __ ] fight
over the annotation and then [ __ ]
fire for this [ __ ] elevating a loose
looks [ __ ] we killed it
enemy time looks like something over
here I've got it okay let me save this
game
fuckin'-a all right
affirmative [ __ ] aliens Advent roof
here play protocol no this [ __ ] because
he's [ __ ] all the way over there
okay on my way
gotta go
[Music]
hey that's bad I'm just gonna warn them
[ __ ] it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
- damage check alright Chad look at that
nothing I'm not trying to [ __ ] and kill
someone
now our here
nailed him status confirmed all hostels
are down in the area is secure status
confirmed mister we want [ __ ] [ __ ]
awesome oh well I hope you'll all learn
something today to never give up okay
never going to never ever give up in
operation for Addington and I was thank
you